I hope you have jotted down this
function now I did say just now in
situations where you've got an
optimization problem often they will
just hand you the model you have to
construct that but just to illustrate
this thing just to illustrate this I'll
just hand it to you so we don't have
focus too much on that pilot problem so
suppose you have some situation and it's
governed by this particular equation
maybe it's the amount of profit you're
making at your sausages or maybe it's
the amount of infections or the amount
of traffic or the amount of population
or whatever it might be okay this
equation models the behavior of the
situation okay and then you can see over
here on the right-hand side I'm just
going to highlight it you get given some
constraints you're like okay maybe X
can't take on any value that you like
maybe X can only take on these certain
values this certain domain okay and then
you get asked find the maximum find the
minimum now I hope you've got this
written down and when you've got a ring
down I want you to highlight or
underline or whatever the word very
small but it's important I like the word
the maximum the minimum now the reason
why I'm highlighting this is because so
far in stationary points and turning
points we've been saying oh you found a
maximum you found a minimum and the
reason why that's important is because
when you distinguish that with the
maximum the minimum right
the turning point you find might not
actually be the maximum or it might not
be the minim you might be able to go
lower than that within your situation
okay but the stationary point might be
the most important point so let's begin
because we're trying to find Max or min
I'm going to start with a derivative so
help me out okay we're gonna go for F
dash X is pretty straightforward go
ahead and go from start 3x squared minus
12x plus 9 last name okay alright so
I've got a derivative now this next
point I could say stationary points
exist when this derivative is equal to
zero okay but I'm gonna push on that a
little bit just actually don't care
about stationary points if for example
they are horizontal points of inflection
these guys look like this right like so
or or like so neither of these
will ever give me a maximum or a minimum
so they're kind of irrelevant to me I'm
really looking for tiny points not
stationary points does that make sense
well not not just stationary points so
I'm gonna write is turning points but
importantly because I'm looking for
turning points I have to say they may
exist when my first derivative is equal
to zero they may exist because I'm gonna
go ahead solve for this but I still
might find some horizontal horizontal
points of inflection so just have to be
cautious okay all right let's go ahead
and solve this guy so I've got 3x
squared minus 12x plus 9 looks to me
like I've got a common factor I can
divide through by namely 3 so we'll
let's go ahead and do that I get x
squared minus 4x plus 3 hopefully you
guys can factorize this for me what am I
gonna get one might see numbers hmm did
you if you got them in here okay
fantastic I think I think I got it in
that blur different answers there does
that do that check out multiplies -
that's - I think okay so what does this
tell us x equals ya I get x equals 1
from this and x equals 3 turn this okay
so 103 fantastic okay
now I found these are going to be
stationary points but I want to find out
are they turning points or not so this
is where my brain transitions into I'm
determining nature the question hasn't
said the phrase determine nature but I
kind of need to work out what kind of
stationary points these are okay Cillian
which 3 from here oh you mean from here
to here okay yes that's a bit sneaky I
guess I kind of are pretty another color
yes because I have factorized right so
you were right to ask that where did it
go I kind of skipped a step I knew that
what I had on the right hand side was
equal to 0 right so whilst I factorize I
also divided through by 3 the right hand
side is 0 0 divided by 3 still 0 okay
all right um just how many nature I've
got a choice have a think first unit is
secondary first to do second or first
second right second right because look
this is really easy to differentiate
again okay and that's going to get then
give me I can work out concavity from
there surround you
substituting in and come to that I've
got to do it at one stage or another
let's have a think about that next
derivative first so f double dash equals
have a look at this guy
6x minus 12 there it is
okay so to determine nature what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna write here to
determine nature I'm about to run out of
space but you guys will be able to catch
up while I'm writing the next thing it's
a determine nature using the second
derivative I've got to check the
secondary at each of these points yeah
and each of these points and that will
give me either concave up or concave
down or maybe no concavity I hope not
okay so let's find out I'm gonna go F
Double Dash of one six take away 12 is
negative six so what does that tell me
about concavity concave down fantastic
so since I've got a negative value for
the second derivative that's concave
down don't skip writing that which means
it is what kind of turning point it's a
maximum isn't it okay so maximum turning
point very good
I'm going to pause there because I think
you can repeat the next thing right
you're going to check this for f double
dash of three you're gonna get a value
out you can actually see you can
anticipate what it's going to be but you
still need to find it right you can't
just say oh I think it's going to be
this you've got to go ahead and do the
actual working whilst you do that I'm
just going to make myself a bit of space
up the top here so you guys keep going